the deal this your boy westside boogie
and you tuned into the boule cav show we
out here
all right man boo leg cab show we got a
special guest in here it's lit
west side boogie you finally let me come
man first of all i've dmd before that's
crazy you'd be ignoring my dms that's
not true it's sorry man i can show you
treat me like the little instagram
thought
hey uh for this stuck video how did
y'all pull that [ __ ] off just for say it
just looked like it was it like an
uncomfortable video to shoot hanging
upside down like that you mean i was
flying through you weren't flying for
real i was i literally was flying
okay no it was hell uncomfortable i hate
that [ __ ] because the [ __ ] uh can i
cuss on this thing of course oh the
[ __ ]
harness yeah they put inside my pants so
for one it's a dude kneeling down in
front of me while my pants is like kind
of down did you enjoy that no you're
funny as hell and i'm already in compton
in the middle of the hood so the homie's
like oh blah blah blah
paul's blood i'm dealing with that and
then it's just uncomfortable like some
and like because it's up against your
skin yeah they need it tight the tighter
it is the safer it is for you so i'm
already like scary about heights and
stuff like that so i'm like put it as
tight as possible so then i had to get
used to like
flipping backwards and like my weight
and stuff like that but it just kind of
reminds like your face and like a few of
the shots reminded me of 50 at the super
bowl a bit that's fine you know what i
mean like hanging upside down you know
me for a little bit about 50 in a
regular video the super bowl he looked
kind of watched that's my boy but
super bowl he was a little heavy when he
pulled down but he wasn't heavy i just
think that's grown-up weight yeah
exactly yeah you say i might look like
grown-up
i got you
anyway when is your album coming out man
it's been a while i know it's been what
three years um was it 2019 2018 2019
yeah 2019. uh yeah soon next
one one of these days i mean listen
you're here for a reason exactly you
know it's rolled out was done i'm not i
didn't just pull up right i'm just
playing i mean you got music out yeah i
do exactly i mean i'm back outside
um
how many songs is on your album
y'all asking me questions i don't even
know if i can answer i'm gonna say what
does that mean twelve to fifteen because
i didn't ask you if eminem everything is
like you know everything is part of
rollout you know you gotta surprise
people but it's just ridiculous you guys
are doing interviews
i know it's [ __ ] up man i love you bro
what are we doing here i don't know
capping
12 to 15. i want it to be for real in my
brain i want it to be 13 but
i'm just i'll be like trying to figure
it out until the day it's released i
probably might take something out or add
some last minute hail mary you never
know yeah yeah is it like because i feel
like uh that's like to me a nice number
for an album yeah and we start getting
into like that 20 21 it's like yeah it's
a little overwhelming sometimes
listening a lot to that much music at
once so i was gonna do 10 but i was like
i didn't make them wait uh three years
to pretend they're gonna be pissed so
um how is everything just in terms of
like just life man we got through a
pandemic you know what i mean obviously
uh that happened i was in the house been
waiting three years for your music so
i'm assuming you've lived a lot of life
in that time
yeah pandemic was was good and bad for
me like as far as like quarantining
because like i had to be in the house
but it also like tested my relationship
that i was in at the moment we ended up
breaking up which like i don't think we
was right for each other anyway you
think the pandemic kind of made y'all
break up like i mean it forced us to be
around each other i think it was
problems we would have kept prolonging
we probably would have ended up breaking
up but not like when we needed to you
know what i'm saying because thank god
it happened before you had a baby or
something that i mean yeah with her yeah
you're right you're right um because i
do got a kid but but yeah but it's not
what the yeah just not with her so um
that happened then also just like
an artist in my head i deal with that a
lot you know i'm saying i can't lie
about that um then going through therapy
and then finally being in a good head
space still struggling some days um so
yeah what up y'all got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good folks over at blue chew now
fellas if you're out there and you're
suffering from a little bit of that ed
erectile dysfunction it's totally normal
it happens you could be stressed out at
work you could be
just having anxiety in life and uh you
know your dick is not up to par well
guess what that's where blue chew comes
in because blue chew
has the same active ingredients as
viagra and scialis and check this out
it's a straight online prescription
service you do not have to go to the
doctor's office you don't have to go
have any like weird awkward
conversations about why your dick isn't
working with a stranger no what you do
is you go to bluechew.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get your first month for free that's
right first month for free all you do is
pay five dollars shipping all right when
i tell you that bluetooth it hits all
right you will uh
you'll be [ __ ] like you never [ __ ]
before let's just say that shout out to
uh bluechu one more time get your first
month free use the promo code bootleg
bluechew.com
it comes right to your door in discreet
packaging open it up it's in a chewable
form and it is that [ __ ] to fight ed so
go to bluetooth.com asap and use that
promo code bootleg and try it for a
month for free
therapy man i feel like uh
something that a lot of people are
comfortable i feel like it's starting to
become normalized i love this gender
like my generation i'm starting to
realize we're so amazing just as far as
like
i look around all my homies as great
parents when i remember us being younger
none of us had our dads and now we like
over like we just overcompensating for
what we didn't have you know i'm saying
we super like dads now um
and so yeah even with therapy like my
home is just starting to be open to it
black and brown community starting to be
open to it so i think it's dope what is
uh what was there anything like
kind of was like your tipping point
where like i need to go talk to somebody
type [ __ ] for me my feelings were just
hurt i was just crying i was tired of
crying the opportunity was presented to
me from lvrn um because you know they
care about the artist's mental health so
shout out to them and i didn't really
want to do it at first it felt like
homework some days it still feel like
class you know what i'm saying because
yeah because i i've been to therapy
sometimes you get like exercises yeah
yeah do this do this and uh we'll meet
next week exactly so having to do stuff
when you leave and it's like man i just
want to come here and not have to deal
with it when i get out of therapy so
it's still a struggle you know i'm
saying but i'm starting to notice the
benefits of it just like i'm more
patient more open to people and like
understanding where they're coming from
and stuff like do you find yourself like
practicing [ __ ] you learn like in real
time you're like oh this is
yeah just like um i get tested still and
the way i'm able to approach the
situation now and i just react out of
like
uh anger or feel like i'm getting
attacked when somebody give me their
opinion on something and i know in the
past that's been my problem is always
feeling attacked when somebody go
against my way of thinking um
what were you so sad about man i got
dumped you know what i'm saying also the
breakup yeah it messed me up um because
i feel like this was like my first
healthy relationship all my other
relationship was like based off like
trauma binding and stuff like that it
was my biggest drama bonding yeah you
know what i'm saying just hurt people
yeah it's like her people love her
people you know what i'm saying so these
work together exactly so this was the
first time i felt like i had a girl who
was like
she was open to my kid like she was
receptive to him she was at the games
with me it was just healthy and i don't
think i knew how to handle that so i
don't think i was a great boyfriend at
the time but also she had a lot of
growing to do and so i think we just hit
our ceiling and
it messed me up because i was my best
friend also you know what i'm saying
that was a part i didn't know how to
like i was just trying to fill that void
because it was just missing so i was
messing with a lot of thoughts and stuff
like that the thoughts the thought is
just to feel that space i didn't know
how to sit sit at home by myself for
more than a day got to have somebody
over
but then also don't want them like being
clingy or kissing on me it's just like
it's just weird
so you kind of used like a
that was kind of like your coping
mechanism
exactly being a thought being at that
yeah
how do you feel you're over it
yeah i still go through days when i'm
mad because i feel like i didn't get no
closure right um i feel like what
happened just disappeared on your way uh
just you know life and her life i feel
like she starts to go through her whole
face i ain't gonna lie i feel yo
honestly that's an important phase to
every girl needs to go and i feel like
she was starting to grow to resent me
because
she still had she had life she needed to
see
um she's also a singer so i feel like
i'm not sure she felt supported in all
the space of her career and i got an ego
too so who knows how i was acting or how
she was perceiving it but i also don't
want to hold her accountable she was
doing weird stuff on instagram you know
she's dating somebody i know now and oh
[ __ ] and stuff like that but
uh what was like for you like was there
a specific reason why it took you so
long to get this album out or do you
feel like it was just
i mean so many different things probably
ended up
accumulating in this i know i could i'm
sure it was because i was in my head a
lot um
i'm so
heavy on like growth in like making sure
my my next stuff is buried in my last
project and i feel like my last project
was so amazing so that first year after
that i was definitely in that bag
when i finally was ready to record again
i feel like i was making the same songs
that i did from everything for sale
because it was my my comfort space
so there was that my manager is having
to be like nah we're not doing this
again you have to find a new pocket so
being frustrated about that took a
minute to get over that hump
um then yeah we finally got to a space
where i had something i wanted to talk
about i also don't know how to draw from
fake spaces i got to find something
something real yeah yeah i'm saying so
um i obviously don't want this to be my
production rate every three years i drop
an album so
i think uh the therapy also like opening
my mind up to stuff is it's been helping
so i think i'm in a great space now so
you mentioned lvrn i mean yeah i bring
it up a lot yeah yeah yeah i know my
managers they're great um shout out to
them shout outs
yo they have some of my favorite artists
me and me and me and me
and i love i love i love black that's my
dog he's amazing huh he's the man
amazing
i love black black's like he's like i
would say he's like in my probably top
five favorite artists of the last like
decade i love black
new music man that's coming waiting
black season i just seen you on
somebody's story the other day so i'm
waiting like you bro yeah
yeah we need some new music yeah for
sure some new merch all that good stuff
um what is for you know cause like i
feel like um
being signed to eminem
has got to be a gift and a curse how how
how would you kind of perceive it
because we always hear like
what curse what do you think is a curse
i mean eminem is you know he's he's uh
the greatest rapper alive that is
what i mean so like when people think of
eminem they think of him being like the
goat you know and
i feel like any time he signs an artist
it's very much expected that that artist
also has to be in that and like think
about he signed you he signed
the griselda guys slaughterhouse back in
the day i'm forgetting i'm sure
some other artists who else is on shady
yellow wolf who yellow wolf yep oh
yellow wolf yeah but that means he's not
on shady anymore no i didn't know that
who's on shady you don't know that i
don't know it kind of falling out oh my
bad i believe [ __ ] yellow
no i don't say that my bad i don't know
royce my dog but let me just tell you
like this i don't think royce is on
shady though but he was at a point come
on man wasn't he i thought they just
forget about that meets evil i don't
think that racism hey you know better
than me
why you thought it out there shout out
to royce though royce one of the best is
really one of my favorite people in the
world he's also one of the greatest
rappers of all time literally i
literally think at any given time he's
he might be the greatest rapper alive
there's like a few of those guys it's
like royce
black thought
uh
i think conway's in that discussion i
think when you're at your peak you could
be in that discussion
if you didn't say something towards me
all about the trip like nah [ __ ] you man
beside me for a reason but what i'll be
saying is like i don't know i never feel
it because
it's it's for one i'm competitive so
it's like everybody's like even playing
field for me obviously i respect
everything how eminem changed my life
but you know what i'm saying i'm still
trying to get to where i'm trying to go
so i don't feel no pressure from
whatever eminem is accomplished because
i like got my own goals and also it's
like the [ __ ] i faced in my neighborhood
it's like once i come to this [ __ ] it
just like there's nothing it's like
whatever what's some little you know
it's a little well not like that's
little white kids on the internet don't
be mad i'm not rapping fast it's the
most
the most is that a thing it is a thing
for real for real my
uh it's like from the outside looking in
a lot of people think i don't fit what
the shady roster stands for you know
what i'm saying eminem know you know i
could borrow at any given time and
that's not i just don't want to do it
all the time so you can borrow eminem at
any given time
you know what i'm saying maybe but i was
just saying he know i could go off right
right at any given time you're capable
of but that's not giving them and i'm
saying i'm more so in delivering my
message and if gray lines come in in the
process of that that's dope little
metaphors and stuff but trying to get my
point across and make great music and
talk to my people so
yeah don't care about what no shady fans
are saying i love the [ __ ] out of y'all
but you know what i'm saying yeah i was
just in detroit i told you i went to a
technician concert in detroit and i saw
with my own eyes
detroit white people like not just
normal white people like detroit white
people like you know like that listen to
insane clown posse and stuff and i was
like
yeah it was just a different different
white trash in detroit hit you you got
to see australian white trash i bet you
they're [ __ ] different but i bet you
they could survive off the grid nah they
it was it was fire 80 000 people five
year olds out there in australia and
australia at this concert and it was
just
wild you opened yep and he brought me
out on he said that's big man super
grateful for that nice guy eminem yes
nice guy uh
i sometimes i feel bad for how big he is
because he can't do some of the stuff
that he would probably want regular
people uh want to do
so i do see he trapped in celebrities
sometimes
but
i'll take that you know
um
i know you obviously wrote on the album
but i just want to get your opinion on
on this kendrick album man amazing it's
incredible right proud to be from
compton shout out to dad what was your
favorite song on the album count me out
countdown's amazing look at that that's
right when i uh
right after we listened i was just the
one i said play back again did you i was
going to say like how did you initially
listen to the album because for me like
we had like premiered at the radio
station
and i was like man i don't want to
listen to it tonight because i can't
give it all the attention i want so i
waited until like saturday or sunday and
just sat with it and my friend made a
thing we it was like my close music
friends like my two producers and
a couple other people i respect and we
had the light slow i was sitting on the
floor with a bottle of champagne and we
just played it through
incredible body work and i feel like
it's like
it's it's it's like the vulnerability
from artists as big as kendrick like
to think how vulnerable he is and that's
the that's the necessary part and i'm
glad you said that because
that's extremely necessary super
necessary somebody that big is still
vulnerable and not yeah yeah
it still goes through like
the same random
human situations yeah because
this is that he opened and talked about
it yeah everyone goes through it but
like not everyone in his position is
gonna share that kind of [ __ ] effects um
you helping summer with her verse like
just give me a little rundown of
how that happened you know we are in
dream team um this the play was brought
to me by justice uh one of my managers
and i just helped her what i could help
with sent it over you know what i'm
saying summer did her thing went crazy
that's got to be up there and like you
know being a kid from compton
yeah yeah i mean you know i'm saying
kendrick
one of my favorite rappers in the world
so would you say because i always say
kendrick is top five deborah alive i
feel like if you could put biggie in
your top five you old dusty ass
[ __ ] by the way i'm one of them
he's got two albums i don't put big in
my top five though but a lot of people
don't like uh
brian guys
from interscope who was here with you
he's an old dusty new yorker i think
he's definitely in his top five yeah off
for two hours i get it though and yeah
but i'm like okay
my top five all dead or alive bro
what yeah effects and he's probably
i mean i feel like if you think of like
first and if we're not even if we're
excluding section 80 but let's even
include like section 80 but like
i feel like the only person who could
[ __ ] with his first four albums is kanye
that's good that's a good point facts
them first four albums was
undeniable because if it's section 80
good kid mad city to pimp a butterfly
damn that's four well i mean if you take
section 80 out let's start with this
good good kid mad city yeah even him
[ __ ]
not including untitled which is kind of
like his lost tapes you know i love
untitled too me too that was my [ __ ]
doesn't get talked about enough
and we got an untitled project from
kendrick that's some real rap [ __ ] like
naz gave us some lost tapes kendrick
gave us untitled yeah he he really gave
us a lot of music
who is your top five that's a weird
question but like you know it's probably
rotating and then yeah
i mean it don't really rotate it's the
same ones i'm not gonna say no order but
i just know it's lil wayne kendrick
jay-z
tupac
eminem
was the last one political
i mean
obviously if you don't say eminem those
dusty white kids are coming for you
on a craft of music yeah he might be
number one if we just talk about every
time my ability to rap is probably
number one exactly so yeah ability of
rapping eminem
could be i mean yeah i mean yeah
discography
you know i agree with agree to disagree
you you love his discography emma's
discography yeah but i'm not going to
debate you on it either yeah i got you
i get it man yeah but yep i love
everything eminem does love his first
three albums everything eminem has ever
dropped is amazing loved his first three
i thought
uh music to be murdered by that [ __ ] was
fire what's your least favorite one had
all his albums oh revive was it revival
was that the one that came out in like
uh where he was
that's the one he said he didn't like
right
one of them he said he didn't like
listen i'm gonna say this about eminem
eminem's one of my favorites ever eminem
show is one of my favorite albums of all
time i love m m show it's my favorite m
album
i just i man
skylar gray on every [ __ ] album
oh
my god shout out to skylar i'm just
tired of skylar graham pink hoods cooks
absolutely i respect that but i did love
recovery was dope that was a newer one i
mean that was it's like 12 years old now
but like recovery was fire and music to
be murdered by
was like a vintage m m album to me it's
because you know what's crazy because
like i just missed like
a lot of people used to talk [ __ ] about
eminem's production but i liked it no it
used to be hard to me too so like on
those albums like especially like eminem
show you would hear like eminem
production and you'd be like oh but then
i feel like he kind of just got away but
music to me to be murdered by was my
[ __ ] i was like this feels like a
vintage eminem project that's amazing
and not a bunch of
you know ballads all right shout out to
skylar gray though
have you met kylo gray yep she was in
australia she's a nice lady amazing lady
nice shout out to her man shout out to
skylar gray man
shout out to her ed sheeran pink all of
them shout outs all of them shout out to
white people man white people in general
man um with your album like you know uh
i know you're not gonna give us any
features
uh because shelly on there but that was
on a single so okay yeah that's already
out uh but anywhere how many rappers how
many other rappers are on the album how
about that just give me that um
as of right now i'm counting four in my
brain if we just say they rap yeah
for the rappers yeah
yeah
no idea when the album's coming out or i
do got an idea an idea i will say in the
next 40 days
that sounds about right yeah i mean you
are making your rounds exactly you know
what i'm saying yeah uh what about like
uh in terms of like your writing process
a lot of times like when i'm in the
studio a lot of artists nowadays i feel
like they do they punch in line by line
you know what i'm saying i can't i don't
i can't i i respect people who do that
and i admire them i just can't do that
that just seems so like
counterproductive for me are you still
putting the pen to paper or no or the
notes no i just i write in my brain i've
been doing that since ninth grade when
my glasses messed up and i can see like
the paper no more but also i just need a
trigger word like if i'm scared i'm
gonna forget the sentence i just write a
word down in my notes oh fire just one
word and then i could connect the bar
i'm gonna remember to borrow my brain oh
[ __ ] like that so will you like do that
like like i guess if you get sent a pack
of beats are you doing that [ __ ] in the
studio are you doing that [ __ ] at home
and then i don't like the studio i hate
the studio i do everything at home i
literally hate the studio
why because it's cold
it's people walking around it's just
like i need my intimate it's my music so
personal to me
i'm not ready for people to it's only a
certain amount of people i trust to hear
it and you record yourself
nah but he with me every day my producer
my engineer there he is one of my best
friends so i can't record myself though
i definitely send him stuff when i'm
just at home yeah when blas blast just
told us that he recorded chosen on a
focusrite
and a road mic
at his house that [ __ ] blew my mind i
was like that's crazy that's like the
250 like package that's what i did my
first project thirst 48 i did at home by
myself too that mic was probably 50
so i just had to stack my vocals a bunch
of times to make it sound full i just
copy and paste copy and paste because i
didn't know how to really do it mix and
master [ __ ] yeah and i just put it out
so
uh what in your you know obviously la i
feel like it's kind of out of
renaissance in terms of like
getting a lot more respect in hip-hop
and you know i feel like there was like
a dry spell you know from like man i was
just with this [ __ ] from la i mean
atlanta the other day he was talking
crazy about la and just how we not
respected outside of la and it was
pissing me off and then he was just like
ready flopped where's dad at we don't
got him and it's like i'll be saying
i'll be one in the world to respect it
but it still feel like we got a lot of
work to do um as far as like what i was
saying yesterday is out here they always
want to bring up atlanta and how
everybody support each other the streets
dictate how la move and you know what
i'm saying everybody can't move around
each other what's going to say do you
feel like that is because i always say
that like sometimes the politics will
get in the way of like
certain artists working together or
like you said people say that about
atlanta but it might not be actually
possible for everyone to move together
out here but i do feel like there is
some sort of cohesiveness with some of
the younger generation when it comes to
like the ruchi's and the one take jays
and
like obviously nationally they might not
be where we want them to be but i just
feel like there's something you know the
the lac is thriving right and that's
what make one take i think we'll make
one take jay amazing because he's he
stayed true to himself he's not trying
to gang bang you know what i'm saying
and that make him able to move in all
these different spaces and we need
artists like that that could do that he
could go do uh work with ruchi and then
go work with blueface and then just be
anywhere you want you know and nobody'll
say anything nobody say nothing and they
and we love them but it's a lot of
[ __ ] it's a lot of upcoming artists
that feel they got to attach themselves
to a neighborhood and that's just young
black men in general they got to feel
like they got to do that to feel like
secure or feel cool so
then that prevents them from being able
to work with other artists because it's
a 30 years of tension between these two
neighborhoods and you just can't do it
yeah it's crazy because uh you know
working my head had had to break down
all the politics that l.a to me one
night when i first moved out here in
like 2017
i was like [ __ ] i had no idea how to say
it's hella sad but people from the
outside that don't live here don't
understand like the intricacies of some
of this [ __ ] cause like we just think of
like
nationally you think in la you just
think bloods versus crips like it's
definitely not that simple no it's not
it's it's bloods versus blood it's blood
it's crips versus crips majority of the
time what it is it's like same old same
now so it's like and it's like the some
of the more heavier uh conflicts are
between
the set you know crips first critics
exactly so
that's tough man and then not knowing
what had to wear in what areas
man i
i remember it was recently i knew
somebody that got that got shot and i
was trying to support him and then i had
commented on the page like hope you get
better and then i know somebody's like
yeah
[Music]
erase the other thing because you know
i'm saying we might have something to do
with that and i'm just like oh happened
man i'm like i never know nothing i'm
just in a dark so it'd be like
that's la politics for you 100 man hey
we got to stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our good folks at odd
socks listen the most comfortable socks
in the entire world i promise you
are these odd socks basics right here
now i like the uh the uh high joints the
whites or the blacks
we're very inclusive at the bootleg head
podcast love the blacks and the whites
of odd socks of course um but they also
got the crazy licenses they got ninja
turtles they got a [ __ ] scarface
breaking bad socks which i just
rewatched amazing and their underwear
the best man i was just talking to
somebody about how fire the odd socks
draws are because the waistband don't
fold they're just comfy as hell so go to
odd socks
official.com you see the website spell
it that same way and use the promo code
bootleg kev all one word together and
you'll get 20 off from our presenting
sponsors our family at odd socks it's
all that's on my ass and feet ladies and
gentlemen so we'll get you some odd
socks let's get back to the interview um
who are some of your favorite la artists
that like are kind of on the come up you
know what i'm saying like that that
you're just a fan of um i like baby
stone gorillas i like what they're doing
um
my young homies i gotta give him a
shameless plug epic must die and kb
devine
um who else i like right now asm the
boxer i think he dope it's uh he's got
that uh i like
your move uh wally he's from my
neighborhood obviously i love wally um
wally's dope wally and yes i love him
key riches three uh youngest from my
neighborhood that i love
and let me see who else out here i said
i want to take jay but he already kind
of up now um while he's dope though
wildly amazing super talented like
you're really right and he yeah i feel
like he makes records that could really
transition like exactly and that's one
of them artists that like that can move
outside of la and people connect to it
you know i'm saying a lot of
what we got to stop doing is stop making
our music just so about like for our
homies and i used to do that early too
like i'm just going to make music for
the hood so when i come to the hood the
hood could be playing it but then when
you go out you want the world to play
exactly then you leave me like what the
[ __ ] sorry i mean that's why
roddy figured it you know right
definitely figured it out that's what
i'm saying once you find the formula
it's up and so yeah even when we had
that wave with mustard and roddy i think
it was a year or two ago
uh
album came out in uh
december of 2019
right yeah yeah yeah it was everywhere
and i feel like that was our chance to
like be back in the world and like
figure it out but you know we still
don't have our shot
but
it's crazy because you think of the
roddy situation and like how long he
took to put put out his album kind of
similar to you obviously yeah um
and i feel like sometimes when you wait
a while you can maybe overthink it 100
and you know it's not it's a real fear
and it's a real thing because
the more they it's always going to be
like oh you made this this wait this
long and you didn't live up to
expectations because you're not going to
be able to please everybody and that one
time you see that could just mess up
your whole mental state i know for me it
will like you know what i'm saying so
it's tough um but you also don't want to
over saturate yourself you also don't
want to rush your product but
you got to let that [ __ ] go you do got
to just let it go and just
create and just give it out to the world
you know what i'm saying yeah low key
man i mean i see i feel like that
sometimes like when we think of like we
all know artists you're one of them i'm
sure that i'm sure you've had songs that
you've recorded in the last three years
that you loved like two and a half years
ago when you first recorded them that
probably didn't make the album because
they might have been old to you yeah did
that happen no i still happen to i just
had to bring an old song back like
two weeks ago because it's old to you
but no one's heard it exactly i see that
[ __ ] all the time but i'm glad i left i
left the song for a little bit and came
back to it and with new ears and i was
like oh i was tripping this song slapped
and that'd be a lot a lot of times too
so
yeah but also i feel like i've rushed
songs out that i was just trying to put
music out and i was like huh i don't
really love this but then i guess that
could happen all the time why do you
think you're still so slept on man
because i feel like you're very slept
off very underrated when it comes to
just the conversations of just the best
rappers you know what i mean like i feel
like you don't get the respect you
deserve what i notice
i i'm super respected by artists it's
like i'm just a [ __ ] that's known in an
artist's world oh yeah not to play with
boogie but it could be consistency you
know what i'm saying like dropping more
that could be a thing i hate the term
slept on because i feel so much love but
i get it when people say it but it's i
don't never really feel it i know i'm
supposed to be bigger but just slept on
always it's like huh it's really my
fault if i'm not it's where i need to
yeah i think it's just like
i feel like an artist like yourself like
i just feel like we just need more music
no that's that's right and i get it so
you know what i'm saying so
that's all it is consistency so that's
this if you're going if any artists want
to learn from me learn from me and like
get out your head and and move forward
you know what i'm saying and get some
therapy if you need it yeah shoot even
if you don't need it you might not even
know you need it we all need it
well i'm talking to black people i know
for sure you got some type of uh
unaddressed trauma somewhere you got to
be have you ever uh
done any hallucinogenics at all like
shrooms or anything yeah and i'm scared
of shrimps right now because that [ __ ]
revealed that i had some crazy [ __ ]
going on in my brain and i'm not doing
it again so i'm gonna to fix myself some
more i like that so you took shrooms and
it kind of like i took it was i cuz i
was against it like forever so just like
last year i had like a month where i did
acid and like shrooms
and that was crazy very therapeutic
thing to do if you do it the right way i
saw all my demons i saw myself and i
hated who i saw shits can change your
life low-key facts and i'm damn near
preaching like [ __ ] need therapy and
shrooms just as much i feel like every
everybody needs to do shrooms once
because like you got to see that [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] was crazy yeah what about
would you ever try dmt man i don't think
i'm ready because i could barely handle
shrooms yeah i feel like dmt you got to
be like really yeah and then what's the
other one ottawa ayahuasca yeah
ayahuasca yeah that's like a
all-day thing you need a championship
like that you need a shaman you gotta
like prepare yourself for your body
probably never be able to come back from
that
i don't know man i know i know a lot of
people you know it's funny because i got
a couple of homies that have done
ayahuasca and they say it's like 30
years of therapy in like six years i
heard that too
it's crazy like so much time go do it i
i want to do it eventually yeah i know
that they have like some groups in like
malibu and santa monica to do it but i
like low-key want to go to like costa
rica uh-huh that's why i heard this but
where's that yeah that's fine but also
i'm like afraid i'm gonna throw up and
[ __ ] on myself yeah and they say you do
that projecting or projectile though
whatever nah mushrooms shrooms are the
wave
yeah like we got to normalize shrooms in
hip-hop man micro dose you got a micro
dose no more perks leave the perks alone
see the perks alone
uh all right well look we're gonna get
an album in the next 40 days mm-hmm 40
days all right uh three days what's next
rappers on it four rappers a singer two
yeah a singer or two singer two is black
on the album
i'm not giving him no info
but also black man on album
listen man
this flies
this flies been flying around this whole
interview
this whole interview this is a co-star
of the [ __ ] interview that's what we
get for leaving the front door open
earlier but yo i appreciate you pulling
up man i can't wait to hear the album
thank you man i'm gonna have him send it
to you early yeah send it to me early so
i can no wrap cap no wrap cap there it
is my guy
take my hand on camera all right yeah
yeah
don't play with this fire appreciate you
man all right we're gonna do uh
a video drop in this camera that one
will you just introduce yourself make
sure you check me out on the bootleg cav
podcast
what's the deal this your boy westside
boogie make sure you check me out on the
boule kev podcast i finally pulled up
with my boy slit
and then um an audio only drop um for
the radio just be like yo what up
west westside boogie and you're
listening to the bootleg cab show
yo what's the deal it's your boy west
side boogie and you tuned in to the
bootleg calf pocket it's not popular